[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video i've got something a
little bit different for you guys i've
covered book drafts and unpublished
content in the past but i don't think
i've ever covered anything quite like
this
today i'm going to be introducing you
all to an alternate deleted unpublished
scene from the chamber of secrets where
instead of crashing into the whomping
willow harry and ron instead crash into
the lake outside of hogwarts now as we
know this particular outcome never
occurred harry and ron crashed into the
whomping willow and that's that but in
this scenario harry and ron find
themselves submerging the lake it's at
this point that they're saved by none
other than mer people newt scamander
author of fantastic beasts and where to
find them describes merpeople as the
following in his book the oldest
recorded merpeople were known as sirens
greece and it is in warmer waters that
we find the beautiful mermaids more
frequently depicted in muggle literature
and painting
the selkies of scotland and the marrows
of ireland are less beautiful but they
share that love of music which is common
to all mer people essentially mer people
are sentient magical beasts that live
under water and as noted above they can
be found all over the world they are
certainly mysterious creatures that we
don't get to know very well in the story
only playing a relatively small role
outside of hogwarts they reside in the
black lake and we really only see them
during the events of the second task of
the triwizard tournament where they
agree to keep four people in an
enchanted sleep in their village for an
hour protecting them until they are
saved by their respective champion
they're certainly odd creatures and
though they were offered the status of a
being in the magical world they refused
in favor of beast mainly because they
did not wish to share a status with hags
and vampires with all that said in this
scene that i'm about to introduce you to
the mer people can be seen saving harry
and ron from the slowly submerging ford
anglia they are able to flip the car
over and drag it back to shore where
harry and ron get out this was the first
time that harry ever saw mer people a
momentous occasion if we look at the top
of page 64 it's very clear that an
editor for the book has made notes
remarking that the chapter in question
may need a rewrite this is probably the
reason we never ended up getting this
scene but it's certainly interesting to
look at so let's dive into it no pun
intended page 62 harry thought happily
of ice cold drinks in the best gold
goblets and platters pound high with
delicious hogwarts food
they flew over the edge of the great
lake now the castle right ahead of them
why are you slowing down said harry i'm
not said ron stamping on the accelerator
i don't understand the car was
definitely slowing now they were going
at a walking pace what's wrong with it
said ron frowning at the dashboard why
isn't it ron said harry suddenly
pointing at a dial beside the steering
wheel we're out of petrol what's petrol
said ron it's what you need to make a
car go said harry irritably well why
didn't you say so before said ron as the
car began to shudder alarmingly i didn't
know a bewitched car would need it said
harry grabbing the edges of his seat as
the car began to vibrate madly on the
spot oh no said ron weakly his knuckles
white on the steering wheel if the
engine cuts out the words were barely
out of his mouth when the engine
spluttered and died
no
ron yelled the car dropped like a
boulder but hit the glassy surface of a
lake with a deafening smash harry was
thrown against a window hedwig was
screaming again ron's foot hit harry in
the mouth
icy water was pouring in from somewhere
and the car sank slowly and steadily
through the blackness
scabbers ran across harry's face
water was sloshing about inside harry
seemed to be sitting on the ceiling of
the car
harry kim ron's voice again through the
dark what how come we're not dead
page 63 the windows have shut themselves
dad must have added safety spells are
you hurt something's bleeding but i
think i'm okay are you all right harry
felt the back of his head i've got a
lump like an egg but nothing feels
broken
how are we going to get out of this
dunno
there was a jolt and an ominous silence
the roof of the car had hit the bottom
of the lake well we can still breathe
said ron but i don't know how long
that's going to last will anyone know
we're here i don't know you can't see
the lake from the train station can you
maybe someone from hogwarts was looking
out of the window yeah maybe said ron
bravely the headlights were still
working they could see a few feet of
murky water and black rocks on the floor
of the lake neither of them spoke for a
while we'll have to thank your dad if we
when we get out said harry eventually
tell him his safety spells worked
yeah
harry ron's voice was trembling did you
see something move out there
harry stared out at the water
illuminated by the headlights there was
nothing there but a few specks of sand
were swirling as though it had been
disturbed what did you think you saw
harry asked it was hard to keep your
voice calm and unconcerned when your
mouth was so dry it looked like an
enormous fishtail whispered wrong page
64. oh well a fish said harry a fish
isn't going to do anything to us i
thought it might be the giant squid
there was a pause in which harry wished
he hadn't thought about the giant squid
there's loads of them said ron
swivelling round and gazing out of the
rear window harry felt as though tiny
spiders were crawling up his spine
large dark shadows were circling the car
if it's just fish he repeated and then
into the light swam something harry had
never expected to see as long as he
lived it was a woman a cloud of blackest
hair thick and tangled like seaweed
floated all around her her lower body
was a great scaly fishtail the color of
gunmetal
ropes of shells and pebbles hung about
her neck her skin was a pale silvery
grey and her eyes flashing in the
headlights looked dark and threatening
she gave a powerful flick of her tail
and sped into the darkness was that a
mermaid said harry well it wasn't the
giant squid said ron there was a
crunching noise and the car suddenly
shifted harry scrambled about to press
his face against the back window about
10 mere people bearded men as well as
long-haired women were straining against
the car their tails swishing behind them
where they going to take us said ron
panicking the mermaid they had seen
first wrapped on a window next to harry
made a circular motion with her silvery
hand i think they're going to flip us
over said harry quickly hold on page 65
they grabbed the door hands and slowly
as the merpeople pushed and strained the
car turned right over onto its wheels
clouds of silt fogging the water hedwig
was beating her wings furiously against
the bars of her cage again the mer
people were now binding thick slimy
ropes of lake weed around the car and
tying the ends around their own wastes
then with harry and ron sitting in the
front seats hardly daring to breathe
they pulled the car was lifted off the
bottom and rose toward the mer people to
the surface
yes said ron as they saw the starry sky
again through their drenched windows the
mer people in front looked like seals
their sleek heads just visible as they
towed the car towards the bank a few
feet from the grassy bank they felt the
wheels touched the pebbly ground of the
lake again
the merpeople sank out of sight
then the first mermaid bobbed up at
harry's window and wrapped on it he
unwound it quickly we can take you no
further she said she had a strange voice
it was both screechy and hoarse
the rocks are sharp in the shallows but
legs are not so easily torn as fins
no said harry nervously
look we can't thank you enough
the mermaid gave a little flick of her
tail and was gone
come on i need food said ron who was
shivering they opened the doors of the
car with difficulty picked up hedwig and
scabbers braced themselves and jumped
down into the freezing water which came
up above harry's thighs they waded to
the bank and climbed out
not as pretty as they look in books are
they mermaids said ron trying to bring
out his jeans of course they were lake
people maybe in a warm sea
harry didn't answer he was having
trouble with hedwig who had clearly had
enough of wizard transport he let her
out of her cage and she sawed off at
once towards a high tower which housed
all the school owls this is the end of
the chapter but i do want to also
mention the note from the editor on page
64. i wondered whether the merpeople
scene actually works after all we don't
see them again what if as an alternative
the car suddenly develops underwater
boosters or something and suddenly
shoots out of the water might help pace
too what you just witnessed was a piece
of harry potter history an unpublished
draft that heavily deviates from the
existing story of one of the most
popular books ever what do you guys
think of it would you have left it in
did you prefer the incident with a
whomping willow had you heard of this
before
comment down below until next time the
truth it is a beautiful and a terrible
thing and should therefore be treated
with caution
[Music]
you